They said only skinny girls can dress well.
I just remembered the sales associate, "Ooh, it will cover her up better."
"We'll hide the stomach better."
"We'll hide her arms better."
They told me that I had to hide.
They told me that I wasn't pretty enough.
They told me that I wasn't thin enough.
I just wasn't enough.
I decided that I needed to be the role model I needed when I was younger.
So, I started my fashion blog.
I want to say, "It's fine to be the way you are."
"You don't have to feel sorry for who I am."
"I'm gonna do what makes me look and feel good."
My style is unapologetic, 100%.
I get stopped all the time by other women.
"I love your outfit."
"I love the way you did your hair, your makeup."
That's the perfect touch to any outfit, is a beautiful dog.
He is gonna look perfect like all my outfits all the time.